with that in mind I guess just wanted to
talk maybe you can maybe elaborate a
little bit around
um some some of the benefits and or
maybe some of the harms of of social
media
um or giving that one social media
yeah yeah
social media as you all know is a toxic
Place yeah has its harms and I believe
the harms are actually a lot greater at
times but what has come through social
media in regards to the platforms uh
that's Instagram and Tick Tock is a
great amount you know we've seen people
through these apps become Muslim except
and on top of that
have a connection with the Sunnah now is
this the best of connections possibly
one could argue no but that's all they
have at least it's something so the
social media realm for somebody that has
nothing for example a person living in
Bosnia or Latvia or Papua New Guinea
they found through this very platform
and means people be browsing you know an
individual from a place in England I
never heard of
saw that on their explore page and they
became Muslim
wow so you know we can clearly see there
are harms but we can also see it's a
realm it's a magal it's an arena where
there are actually people out there
looking for hair looking for goodness
they are depressed they're just
scrolling and scrolling and scrolling
and they find maybe a one quote Yeah or
something that hits home so well and by
way of that they start investigating
yeah and this is personal experience
that I've had with people they've come
to the data in the most remote places
and have realized wow